so today we are going to see my friend
is his name is aria he he went to my
college and you know he's into startups
and he's into engineering also and that
it's been a while I haven't seen him so
he reached out to me and he wanted to
hang out so Yo Yo Ma oh oh and also I
[ __ ] hate that guy
[Music]
it's been too long man yeah man's been
like what college crazy
so you still working for Microsoft
actually I run a startup now Oh have you
gone through series eight yet
well actually I'm funny myself with
bitcoins oh nice
I'm hungry so what about you where are
you up to
oh we just sold another company I'm just
relaxing now trying to figure out what
to do next like I always think why do
VCS always choose my companies you know
it's actually a hassle or enough choice
too much yeah I mean yeah me too I mean
I told you oh hey you still play chess
right yeah I still dabble yo you up for
like a friendly game yeah
friendly it's anything but friendly I'll
crush you awesome Han I'm so rusty but
I'd love to you love to put you back in
the poorhouse
I've memorized over 300 openings and
practice every day for the past year
yeah yeah no I'm pretty trashed to Italy
haven't played in a while
Kings gambit by far my best opening
especially if he accepts it alright Joe
ah
I accept your gambit you've activated my
trap card little does he know this is my
best opening first I play Knight f3
then he responds of g5 and then cooked
an h4 double by attack what is this
you thought I'd play G fly didn't you
it's the wagenbach opening and I'm
conventional but dangerous opening much
less study than the classic variation I
don't mind a little variation
[Music]
[Music]
as Queen what a blunder victory is mine
rookie mistake
I guess you haven't improved oh my gosh
in the
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
your first employees they can either
make or break your company for not line
comm we have to make sure we hired the
right people to build the foundation of
our company
today we are joined by my advisor
Mattoon entrepreneur angel investor and
philanthropist he's known to be the wolf
of Silicon Valley all right so let's
start so wait you want to work for not
mine
yeah that works very bold I like it
silence is dope my parents want me to
get out the house boy and I think this
is a cool company so you know pretty
excited you're everyone YouTube had a
security hack yeah that was me
okay I am the most qualified person for
this job I have been studying online
video for years between vine Vimeo
YouTube I know it all so what kind of so
what kind of skills you have I can write
code okay a writing code I know Java I
took a class in Java and you know I get
[ __ ] done yeah thank yes it works yeah
yeah there we go hmm well they say my
only two pythons my coach Shawn is I
know Steve sharp my coat so sexy it
should be rated R I code so fast like
Elise wit I know [ __ ] bye no basic
let's go
[Music]
what do you want work on I want to be
the CTO in Hawaii I'm deal you know I'm
good with anything I'm just really
excited to work on not mine I really
like vine so you know cool idea guys
I want to build on finds infrastructure
I want to be the greatest app all time I
want to make sure that whenever anyone
is on that site they're having the
experience of a lifetime I'm not gonna
hack together [ __ ] like Windows Vista
all right so the next question just a
formality we're gonna ask you to do a
little bit of a coding question it's
quite simple um here's a laptop
basically what it is is you have to find
a missing number out of a 1 to 100 and
you just start writing a code let me do
I want me to coat this um Joma I thought
this was just a formality
this is easy as [ __ ] do you want me or
not don't give me this [ __ ]
interview yeah my boy Carl Gauss figure
this [ __ ] out in 1783 can I have some
water
[Music]
here Silicon Valley's finest what quoi
[Music]
it's perfect
that is quick pretty good I mean looks
good to me all right I think I'm done
good
it [ __ ] wait what do you mean I mean
they got the answer right it's gonna
take a million years to Ron yeah but
like like there's comments and stuff
like that it's good documentation dude
we're not Microsoft so take it the job
all right first son me she's amazing
she's the best ab you've seen so far
she's solid when it comes to technical
skills a CTO absolutely whatever camera
Cameron he's a straight shooter
he knows five languages and is the best
Python he never makes any mistake the
straight hopper
all right now John no come on no I mean
it's my friend I can go all night
look I know I know his code is not
perfect and I know he may not be the
smartest guy but I do think they can add
a lot of value to our company
he does have a lot of heart
[Music]
all right so I guess we're all get then
let's build not one what's poppin now if
you like this video don't forget to
subscribe and also press the bell
because that will give you a
notification whenever startup four will
come out and if you want to see behind
the scenes and you know just extra
footage or maybe like the director's cut
and stuff like that I'm going to post it
on patreon so if you want to please
support me on patreon
it'll cost a dollar a month and you'll
be able to see all the other content and
also news I have a Facebook page now
please like that page because I'm gonna
use it to do announcements from now on
because I realized there isn't any good
way for me to announce things
permanently so I'm gonna be using my
Facebook page to announce things and I'm
going to post extra content in there
yeah so I'm gonna have that link down
below and don't forget to like it and
yeah this could be great lastly I just
want to say thank you so so much
for 10,000 subscribers honestly that
number is freakin crazy and I just have
nothing to say because my goal for 2018
was to hit 10,000 subscribers and I did
it in one month all thanks to you guys
thank you so much oh and because I hit
10k it means I've reached two thousand
five hundred five thousand and ten
thousand so stay tuned because I am
going to announce another giveaway
alright that's it thanks for watching
again and thanks for tuning in see ya
[Music]
yes